Let's talk about the Twitter meltdown a little
bit here.
Donald Trump managed to tell.
Eight lies about the election in just a handful
of tweets overnight, and I do mean overnight
and it was a bizarre evening for Donald Trump.
His presidency is entering the tenth to last
week of his presidency, spreading disinformation,
retweeting violent out of context videos.
And because of his tweets, I'm going to be
able to tell you three or four different stories
that I wanted to talk about anyway.
So we'll use the tweets as a sort of jumping
off point.
So first to reset as night had fallen.
I already read this earlier.
I want to read it one more time.
And in sort of fact, check it.
Trump tweeting, Why does the fake news media
continuously assume that Joe Biden will ascend
to the presidency?
Well, because he won, not even allowing our
side to show which we are just getting ready
to do, how badly shattered and violated our
great constitution has been in the twenty
election.
It was attacked perhaps like never before.
That's untrue.
Aside from anecdotal instances of, you know,
the Pennsylvania lieutenant governor found
to irregularities both involving Republicans,
but it was an election that was relatively
secure, quite secure from large numbers of
poll watchers that were thrown out of vote
counting rooms in many of our states so that
there were people who weren't actually poll
watchers who were told, you can't be in here.
But every state had both Republican and Democratic
poll watchers as this as this part of the
rules to millions of ballots that have been
altered by Democrats.
Completely untrue.
No evidence for that whatsoever to using radical
left owned Dominion voting systems.
That's another conspiracy which is being used
to claim millions of votes were digitally
flipped to Biden.
No evidence of it whatsoever.
Those responsible for the safeguarding of
our Constitution cannot allow the fake results
of the election to stand.
The world is watching.
Well, the results are real and they will stand.
So, you know, it's deceptive to attack the
media for not pretending.
Trump maybe once said he didn't.
The idea that Trump doesn't get to show his
side is a lie.
They've gone to courts 10 times.
All the courts say there's nothing here.
And there are like five lies just to start
with right off the bat.
Then at midnight, Trump is still going.
He tweets simply, I won the election.
Now that's a lie.
Joe Biden won the election.
Then Trump retweeted a bunch of nonsense,
including a tweet from a random sycophant
who said have have changed to Newsmax and
018.
They are so much better.
This is part of Trump's new ongoing attack
against Fox News for not, I guess, being sycophantic
enough to Donald Trump.
Then Trump in the middle of the night retweeting
his own prior tweet where he said, quote,
Antifa scum ran for the hills today when they
tried attacking the people at the Trump rally
because those people aggressively fought back.
And Tifa waited until tonight when ninety
nine percent were gone to attack innocent
Magga people.
DC police get going, do your job and don't
hold back.
Now, this is important.
Trump also started retweeting a lot of deceptive
videos of violence meant to imply that all
you saw in DC was random.
Trump is walking by on their way to do community
service, I'm sure getting attacked by left
wingers.
There were video.
There's a guy named Endino spelled NGO who
was tweeting a bunch of these, Dave Ruban,
cultural critic and arbiter of ideas, Dave
Rubin, who had an awakening that pulled him
away from liberalism towards, I guess, voting
Trump a few years ago.
They were all tweeting these videos purporting
to be of innocent.
Trump is getting beaten.
And incredibly, I even covered some of these
on my Twitter.
Many of these videos that these right wingers
and Trump were tweeting out were they were
indeed of Trump being attacked after these
same Trump hosts were running wild on the
streets of DC, punching people, including
women, and and committing what appear to be
multiple different felonies.
And Trump continued to tweet a lot of those
trash videos all night.
Will Trump's Twitter be suspended when Trump
is no longer president?
That's the question.
When Trump is no longer president, his Twitter
account will no longer have certain public
person protections.
One would imagine that it would be appropriate
to suspend Donald Trump's Twitter account
at that point in time.
And again, I want to go back to this because
it's so important.
The most dangerous part of this is that Trump's
followers believe it.
Trump's followers believe Joe Biden didn't
win legitimately.
Trump's followers believe that DC was mostly
anti violence, which it, of course, was not.
And it reminds us that the real danger isn't
someone like Trump who says this stuff.
It's a country where 50, 60, 70 million of
your followers believe anything you say to
some degree or another.
That's really the danger and we'll have more
coverage of this on our Instagram page